[Music]
hi I'm Toby and welcome to the joy of
mathematics all you will need to be able
to follow along at home is a pen some
paper and a vision in your mind today
we're going to be exploring the square
root of AI it's a curious question with
a delightful answer don't let the
mathematics scare you away I'm here to
walk through every step with you talent
is just pursued interest anything that
you're willing to practice you can do i
is our favorite imaginary friend but our
relationship with them is complicated
it's mostly their fault in fact i is a
complex friend if we use a smiley face
to refer to all of our complex friends
we can write them as X plus I Y where x
and y give the address of our friend on
the real and imaginary axis real friends
can be complex too they just have a
y-value of 0 and it's our Y on this axis
and our X down here if we draw a
straight line between the origin and
where our friend is we can call that our
and it actually allows us to set up some
triangles in here where this angle here
is Theta using a bit of trigonometry we
can actually rewrite expressions for x
and y using sine and cosine so X will be
this distance here and it will be our
cosine of theta
why this one here will be our sign of
theta now if you've seen my first joy of
mathematics video you may remember
something called Euler's formula and it
was a very beautiful expression I will
remind you of it here it is e to the I
theta is equal to cosine theta plus I
sine theta now you may see that we're
dealing with us already we have a cosine
theta plus I sine theta in here so
actually we can use Euler's formula to
rewrite this expression up here I'll get
rid of it since we now know what we can
do
go and just beat the oiler out of it
friend is going to be our e to the I
theta if we just want to talk about our
friend I for a second we can get rid of
all this general case
well I is going to be up here at a
distance of 1 from the origin that in
fact places I on the unit circle which
are the points that are all a distance
of one away from the origin
don't know how good I'm doing a circle
today but there we go good enough to
write down I like this
we know that R is going to be equal to 1
but what is theta going to be one way to
find theta would be going like this up
from the real axis to our eye to our
imaginary axis now if 2 pi radians is
the rotation it takes to get all the way
around the circle then this quarter of a
rotation right here will be PI over 2
now there's another way to write I and
that's by rotating around this way now
likewise this one is going to be e to
the minus this time because we're
rotating the other way I and it's going
to be 3 PI over 2 it's time for a
friendship test here and we want to test
to see that if the square root of our
complex friend is written like this
what's the solution going to be is he
complex can we trust them I don't know
we can say that the square root of any
complex friend is some other number Z
now if we make both of these guys a
little bit more square a little bit more
uptight we can write complex friend is
equal to Z squared now if we subtract
this from this arrange everyone to equal
zero we get Z squared minus our complex
friend is equal to 0 now this might not
look like
but it's actually kind of important for
us what we have here is a polynomial
it's a polynomial with a degree two it's
a quadratic and that means that we can
use something called the if T a now I
know what you're thinking but this is
not friendly trees anonymous instead
this is the fundamental theorem of
algebra the fundamental theorem of
algebra means that any polynomial with
complex coefficients will have complex
solutions now do we have complex
coefficients here
well our coefficient in front of the Z
squared 10 is 1 we don't have as it term
on its own so that B as it's usually
called as 0 and this is our constant
term here and the coefficient and of our
constant term is our complex friend so
we do have complex coefficients
therefore we know that the answer to the
square root of I will be a complex
number too in fact we know that there
will be two solutions because this gives
us a polynomial of degree two this is
just useful to know so we know how to
write and treat our answer as we're
going forwards now back to I you might
know that the square root of a number
can be written as that number to the
power of 1/2 so we could write the
square root of I as I to the power of
1/2 and then we can just do the same
thing to these terms we would have e to
the I PI over 2 to the power of 1/2 I'm
writing or for these two solutions e to
the minus I 3 PI over 2 it's the power
of 1/2 to work these out just bring this
exponent inside of this one and multiply
them out we would get e to the I PI over
4 and e to the minus I 3 PI over 4 now
we can actually find these solutions on
our unit circle over here
so a thater of pi over 4 it's going to
be to do half way up here that's going
to be our first solution to the square
root of I our next solution will be
minus 3/4 pi which would place us
opposite over here that's what our two
solutions look like graphically I've
made a little bit more room for
ourselves so we can then take these
answers that we've already found
graphically and if you choose to convert
them back into the original form we just
do that using the reverse of Euler's
formula so putting them back into sine
and cosine for our first solution we
would have theta as PI over 4 so we
would have cosine PI over 4 plus I sine
PI over 4 now cosine of PI over 4
actually works out to 1 over root 2 and
in a similar way we would have plus I
times the sine of that which is also 1
over root 2 so that is actually our
first solution to the square root of I
now you could do the exact same thing
using a negative 3/4 pi as you know our
argument in here or you can look at our
visual plot and know that if this was
our first solution our second solution
will be the negative of both of these
values because we're in the opposite
quadrant here on the graph so our second
solution will just be minus 1 over root
2 minus I 1 over root 2 and those will
be our two solutions as shown there for
the square root of I now the dislikes on
this video might come from people who
are upset I didn't rationalize this
denominator you could rewrite these
fractions as root 2 over 2 I believe but
they look cute enough as they are to me
these solutions kind of makes sense if
you think about it visually for example
this rotation from here to here
if you repeat it once again you get to I
and same with this on here you repeat
this rotation again you get back to eyes
so that's how you find the square root
if you wanted to find the cube root you
would end up with three equally spaced
solutions where if you repeat them twice
more you get back to I and you can even
try finding out the cube root of I it's
a very similar technique although you
might want to think twice about how you
find the - I guess definitions of I
instead of like this way in this way you
might want to just keep adding on two pi
or a full rotation every time you're
trying to define I to get the number of
solutions you need thank you for joining
me here today in the garden and I hope
you have an absolutely mathematical day
this is Henry and he's jealous that
Skittles got included in one of my
previous videos but he didn't so now
it's his time for a video
[Music]
you